-That's what I'm talking about!
Welcome back. Tim Allen.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's a pleasure
to have you back.
Thank you for being here.
You look good, bud.
-It's just great to be here.
This is going --
It seems to have been 10 years.
-It is, right?
I wanted to ask you, by the way,
I know you're good friends with
Jay Leno.
And he just got out of
the hospital today.
-He's great. They said -- He's
one of those heroes that --
Remember the "Deadpool" villain
that couldn't feel pain?
-Yeah.
-He's that guy. I saw him.
I called him the day of
the accident --
Our shops are close to
each other.
We play around with
hot rods and stuff.
And one of his mechanics called
and said,
"Jay's in a bad accident."
And I don't -- What do you do?
He's going to the hospital.
What am I'm going to do?
All I can do is leave a message.
He calls, like, back
five minutes later.
"Hey, Tim, what's going on?"
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, sorry, Jay. I heard you
were in a bad accident."
"Yeah, burned all over.
Third-degree burns on my hands,
on my face, everything."
I go, "Uh, uh,
where -- What are you doing
right now?"
"I'm holding the phone.
It's really painful."
[ Laughter ]
And he's not on painkillers.
He said, "And I'm not doing
painkillers."
"Why not?"
"Pain is there for a reason."
-[ Laughs ] Oh, my God.
-What do you say to that?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-"O-Okay."
"Okay. I think pain is there to
tell you to take a painkiller.
Isn't that what
it's supposed to do?"
-That's what pain tells you.
-Went and saw him and he's just
an amazing human being.
He just wanted to get
out of the hospital.
And he's --
It was one bit after another.
We sat and talked for a lot.
-That's hilarious.
-I get interviewed and they said
he's -- "He looks terrible."
I said, "Well, he generally
didn't look that good
to begin with."
[ Laughter ]
-He would like that.
-Every comic said the same joke,
but when you get under pressure,
you say that, people go,
"Oh, that's terrible."
-Yeah, no. Jay would love that.
-Yeah.
But he's going -- He said he's
going with the Clooney look.
And he looks really good
considering the grafts he's got.
The picture today, it is amazing
what they can do.
The hospital did a great job.
-We hope a speedy recovery, Jay.
We love you, bud.
Yeah, it's good to hear.
Thank you for the update on him.
[ Applause ]
-Mm-hmm.
-It's probably good 'cause he
probably wants another comic
to come in and do jokes,
which is good.
-We were just riffing.
It was so stupid.
He's all bandaged up.
"Yeah, I'm not on painkillers.
I don't feel like
no painkillers."
I kept looking.
I go, "Could I use some?"
Because I'm --
-Yeah.
-"I'm in pain watching you."
[ Laughter ]
-You told me that you recently
went on a safari.
-Oh, yeah. Because of COVID,
it was supposed to be --
whenever that was,
back in the '30s.
It seems like it was years ago.
[ Laughter ]
And we went to Zimbabwe,
Tanzania, Kenya,
all through Eastern Africa.
And it was -- The country is
gigantic, number one.
-Yeah.
-And you get -- I've gone to
Egypt and Northern Africa,
which is no relation
to Southern Africa.
I learned that.
But mostly, it's a huge zoo,
but it's the opposite.
You're in a cage, and there's
animals running everywhere.
-Yeah, you're living in a zoo.
-You're sitting in
this little vehicle.
And I said,
"Do they know we're here?
Do they seem to care
that you're there?"
So, the best memory I have,
driving up
in one of these vehicles,
and I looked, the guy says,
"If you look to your left,
there's a lion."
And you look -- and I couldn't
see it because he was
literally -- I could have
touched his nose.
I went, "Oh, geez, oh, God."
-Wow.
-And the lion's there.
And he goes, "His brother is
next to him."
I go, "I can see that.
Are we supposed to be
this close?"
He goes,
"They don't care about us."
-Is that right?
-"They care about the buffalo
they killed on the other side of
the road."
You look over there
and there's a dead buffalo
with its butt eaten out,
whatever they -- lions --
[ Laughter ]
It's kind of
a disgusting process.
I guess they start...ass first.
I've never seen anything
like it.
[ Laughter ]
Well, I don't know
what they were doing.
But they weren't eating it.
We're going like this.
They said they're just --
"What are they looking at?"
He goes, "Well, you --"
[ Chuckles ]
"You never want to be between
a lion and their prey."
And I'm going, "So you wouldn't
want to be kind of
where we are?"
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly where we are right now.
-And the driver goes, "Oh, man.
We should back up."
-Yeah, hold on a second.
-Yeah.
"Is this the first time
you've done this, sir?"
-I want to mention, by the way,
your stand-up tour.
You're going to be in North
Charleston, South Carolina.
And on January 7th,
you're in Boston.
-Good one.
-Thank you.
You can check all this out
on timallen.com.
-This is why we rehearse.
-Yeah.
North Charleston.
Have you ever been there before?
-I've been both of these places.
This has been a year.
Speaking of, you know, Leno goes
out like 200 dates a year.
I've been doing comedy for
30 years, the same opening act.
My whole business got
started on --
My first act was
"Home Improvement."
I sold that. I've done this.
And we were talking backstage
about this, about --
Comedy has changed a little bit.
Comics don't have, um, unions.
We're a burlesque union is
really what it is.
So people can steal your jokes.
That's just what they do.
-Yeah.
-And one -- And we're all
looking for a hook.
So, I'm doing this gig in Canada
when I first started out.
And NBC wanted to see me at the
time because I was getting
this hook with this grunting
and all this tool stuff.
And I'm following a guy named
Chris Lyman.
And you look out the -- and his
manager is introducing him
buck naked with the ugliest male
body parts
I've ever seen in my life
from the back.
They're not that handsome
on any angle.
But from -- on a stool, you're
going, "Boy, if you can see
the unit on a stool --"
You're going,
"What the hell is
going on here?"
-Yeah.
-The guy goes out buck naked,
does his whole act and ends --
I don't know how he was holding
it or where it was exactly
but he had a Roman candle
sticking out of his rear end,
and he's spinning around going,
"There's no business
like show business."
And he's spinning around
and there's a Roman candle
going in the audience.
And the guy -- It goes, "Fft,
fft, fffft," and it goes out.
He goes back, and the guy says,
"Thank you, Chris.
And now comedian Tim Allen."
[ Laughter ]
-"How do I follow that?"
-How do you follow a guy with
a Roman candle in his rear end?
He comes backstage on his way
back, covered up and go,
"Excuse me, excuse me,
excuse me."
Like, "Oh, so, now you're modest
after this."
[ Laughter ]
-Now you're professional. Yeah.
-The whole room is fill with
half smoke --
acrid smoke with NBC execs.
Everybody is out there going --
[ Coughing ]
-You go, "What the --
-"What did I just see?"
-Yeah. But yet, you did it.
-Yeah, I did the bit.
-You followed it.
-Followed the bit. And my
career, well, it took off.
So I guess it was something
for somebody.
-You did pretty well. Yeah.
I want to talk about your new
series, "The Santa Clauses."
You're getting back in the suit.
Does the holiday --
Is it a change for you now?
-At this time of year,
it's become kind of
this iconic piece come back.
And the only reason
I wanted to do it,
I'm kind of a sci-fi freak,
and I want to make sure
all the holes in the script
are -- I never understood,
even in the movie,
why the elves, when I showed up
at the North Pole, didn't go,
"Hey, what happened
to the other guy?"
You know, I just hop
in the sleigh
with the kid and we go off.
No one ever asks, "Where's --
Does Mrs. Claus know
that the other guy is dead?"
"Did the other guy die?"
-There's holes in the plot.
-It was huge holes. "Why does
Mrs. Claus have a name?
What's her first name?"
And that -- So, they --
We came up with this script,
"The Clauses."
I have a family now.
And they end up doing all --
They fill up the holes
in all this.
I should interrupt this.
My kid was in it.
And my youngest kid, I wanted
her to be an elf as a surprise.
She ended up reading
the dialogue so well
that the kid got the lead in it.
-Yeah, she's --
-She's Santa's daughter.
-She's gorgeous, by the way.
I met her backstage, Elizabeth.
-It's just -- It was the most
amazing occurrence.
She'll even say it. I get --
No matter how mad I am,
I come on the set, big set they
got in there in Hollywood.
And they go, "He's on the move,
he's on the move.
Santa's on the move."
And I'm just mad and sweaty.
I'm already mad.
But you show up on set.
You got adults, grips,
camera people, sound.
Everybody goes, "Oh, look."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Because you've become
this thing.
-Jolly.
-And so I got to stop swearing.
-Yeah, yeah. But I -- It's
an interesting story about
your daughter getting cast
because she's --
How old is she?
-She was 13 the day she started.
The girl in the movie, Sandra --
Sandra Claus is 13.
And, again, it was one of these
audition processes that I just
wanted her to read, say,
"Hi, Santa,"
as a Christmas gift as an elf.
Just walk by once.
-And you thought it would be
something fun
for you and your wife
to always have.
-She's great in school.
My daughter is real good
in sports.
We just didn't want her
getting this.
-Yeah.
-She read it so well,
drilled it.
-She nailed it.
-Oh, God.
-Yeah, I have a picture of you
and your daughter here.
It's so cute.
[ Audience aws ]
And you were telling me that you
go -- you got real emotional.
-Oh, well, this is
a real emotional scene.
This one comes out --
The first two, as they dropped,
and now the series starts
this week.
And this scene, I'm trying to
convince her I want to retire
and go back to Chicago where I
started the whole thing.
And she says, "I'm afraid."
And I said -- I get choked up.
She goes, "I'm afraid.
Are you afraid?
Have you ever been afraid, Dad?"
I said, "of course,
but I would be less afraid
if we could be afraid together."
And I'm doing that with my kid.
I'm looking in her eyes.
I'm going, "Whoa, man."
This was -- It was --
It was unbelievable.
-Everyone was crying.
-Oh, everybody was crying.
-It's awesome.
It's heartwarming
but it's also funny.
I tell you who really is funny.
Peyton Manning gets
some good laughs.
And Peyton --
[ Laughter ]
Here's you and Peyton Manning.
How is it like doing a scene
with Peyton Manning?
-Well, this was nuts.
I'm a huge football fan.
-Yeah.
-Sorry about the Giants.
Well, I'm from Detroit,
so it was the weirdest football
game ever.
-Yeah, I know. But they're still
having a good season.
People are still happy.
-I understand.
I'm a Giants fan from way back.
Anyway, Y.A. Tittle sent me
a letter when I was a kid.
He's a big Giants --
Long story short.
Anyhow, Peyton's on the show,
but I'm dressed as Santa Claus.
So he's doing the same look
to me.
He's going, "Ho, ho.
Look at you."
I go, "No, man. I'm a fan."
But I'm under seven feet of
makeup."
And I was like a kid
because he's really good.
And he said, "Oh, look at you.
I want a football."
He's doing -- He's like --
-He never said,
"I want a football."
[ Laughter ]
-He was so natural and so funny.
He's so engaging because I --
The story is I'm auditioning
new guys to be Santa.
And he's got
a good football record.
And I thought maybe that would
make a good Santa Claus.
Drilled the scene.
-I want to show a clip.
Here's Tim Allen
in "The Santa Clauses."
Take a look at this.
-Okay, okay. How about this?
Give us your best "ho, ho, ho."
-Oh, okay. Here we go.
Ho, ho, homaha! Homaha!
You see that?
I called a little audible there.
-He --
-He's odd, yet somehow perfect.
-He's odd, alright.
I don't know if we have a hat
big enough for that head.
Phew.
Look at the size of that thing.
-What's gotten into you?
We need to find someone quickly.
-What's the rush?
-Well, breaking in new Santas
take time.
-Breaking in a Santa.
We're talking about Santas,
not horses.
-I know. Horses listen.
-Ha, that's a good one.
-Are you still here?
-Yeah. Tim Allen, everyone!
New episodes of
"The Santa Clauses"
are available
every Wednesday on Disney+.
Lacey Chabert joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.